قاتل وحكمه باطل هكذا تقول حكم الخائف
ايضا بحسب واشنطن فاعدموا رهن ورد يعكس
حالته هل على السلطات من تحطم جدار الخوف
سقوط الولاء مجيد رضا اعدم علنا في مشهد
رمز الدين المتحالف مع السلطه ومسقط راس
خامنئي رساله واضحه للعمق الفارسي لكن رهن
ورد الذي استند الحكم اليه بناءا على هذا
المقطع غير الواضح بقتل عنصرين من البسيج
كان ثاني المحتاجين على مشنقه النظام سبقه
محسن الشيكاري باربعه ايام اصاب احد
العناصر بجروح فاعدل وهناك العشرات
وغيرهما هناك صدرات 23 سنه
كسر هاتفها بسيجي
يسقط هو النظام صوت 2 20 عن كم نتحدث 20
الف تقريبا بالاعتقال 500 شخصا بالقتل
والعشرات بالانتحار
الشوارع بمدارس امنيه يخلق ما تبقى من
حريه او هكذا يظن النظام
اكلنا المراه الحياه الحريه
[تصفيق]